tidewater dear Hey
what again so you want to make a
Tarantino film well you came to the
right place as one of the most
innovative filmmakers of the 90s he is a
difficult artist to replicate but I'm
confident that with these simple tips
you'll be on your way to creating your
very own blood spatter and masterpiece
before you even think about making a
movie you need to watch a few of them
and by a few I of course mean hundreds
and hundreds you need to eat drink and
breathe cinema once you have an
expansive knowledge of every film ever
made it's time to start making your
movie start by writing a script that
floats whatever is traditionally
associated with a genre on its head such
as a Western about a black bounty hunter
that takes place in the antebellum South
a world war two films starring Nazi
killing Jews or a heist film where you
never actually see the robbery the main
thing you have going for you in these
scripts is the dialogue it should be
funny witty cool and snappy it doesn't
have to have that much to do with the
story it just needs to be interesting
and honestly what is more interesting to
talk about than movies TV and music
you've seen a movie where car gets into
some smash-up day but mine glass after
garage you know the show The Virginian
well the way they pick TV shows where
conversions not about some sensitive
girl but man undercover cops got to be
Marlon Brando and Greer did the film
person love was like Pam Grier TV show
without Pam Grier I find the whole
mythology surrounding superheroes
fascinating that's - Monroe's no it's
not that is malleable wrong that is
maybe even dorm tent at moto meaning
that aren't alone Green eight the script
should also contain drugs all you did
was snort some that Cokie gave him this
is Pamela surprised me every
- the wild will pop every time I bought
some wheat black and white suits
what should you do
and lots of uses of the n-word every
Rhino said dead storage what's going on
to pipe it if we give it Burcu not
around my is fighting Bobby does if who
is the hero of your film well there
isn't more each one of your characters
is an antihero even if their intentions
are good they are still violent ruthless
individuals who should you cast in your
film well the only real answer to that
question is of course samuel l.jackson
don't be telling me about foot massager
tape man that's the most popular girl in
America crash I'll show you no problem
with Shoshana you come here too bad next
you move into production and this is
where your encyclopedia knowledge your
film comes into play every aspect of
your film should be directly stolen from
another movie don't be a and you folks
are square in your must rip hair on oh
my god and I will strike down upon thee
with great vengeance and furious anger
and I will execute great vengeance upon
them with furious anger
hey good-looking be back to pick you up
later hey good-looking we'll be back to
pick you up later
there's some repugnant this is some
stuff repugnant causa
let this sees why was
the soundtrack to your movie should be a
compilation of rock pop and hip hop
songs from the 70s and 80s so
essentially your uncle's mixtape ever
listened to Kay Billy's super sounds of
the seventies stop this meal and how
would you figure out something that
works why change it you should use the
same shots over and over and over again
do that thing oh okay
to do anything where's the brown
her name was for Neeta
dorababu nigga limit you plastic
you do it your one doing a bunch of
gangsters a lot then one day she eats
this John Holmes you didn't fall in a
ditch
no me Fabiana gonna leave in the morning
how are you are you no doubt about it
why ain't going back to jail I'm through
never again back to the whereabouts of
your - angling to win million money you
overreacted put the bag on the floor
okay apparently that's where your wife
is
man Hermosa Beach yeah dad's got to be
from Wisconsin hey you ain't got no
problem Jules
I was amazed what good is a movie
without violence and what good is
violence without buckets of blood
exploding in every direction no one
wants to just hear gunshot they want to
see the person being murdered burst into
a Crimson wave of gore
and finally the last thing you need to
make a movie on par with a Tarantino
film is constantly shoot your actresses
feet and that's it follow these simple
instructions and you'll be on your way
to creating your very own Quentin
Tarantino film